there are at least four mineral
deficiencies that can significantly
affect your iq
that's the topic for today generally
speaking it's your intelligence it's
your ability to solve problems it's your
ability to learn and understand certain
things there's a memory or a recall
component to it
and some people say well you know what
your intelligence is really finite and
either you're born with it or you're not
that's absolutely not true okay you can
have training you can do
self-improvement you can do a lot of
things and even what your mother ate
while she's pregnant has a factor on
your intelligence and your future
ability to solve
problems as you're going to find out but
there are other factors too like with
learning
it could be that you're in school and no
one ever taught you
how to study or learn and i'm being very
sarcastic because they don't teach kids
how to study or learn you're just
expected to know that so you go in there
and you sort of memorize you re-read you
rewrite things over and over and
hopefully somehow you pass the test and
you get through it but today i want to
really focus in on the
nutrient part of your intelligence so
probably one of the most influential
trace minerals which you don't need a
lot of it but you need a little bit of
it and if you don't have that little bit
you're going to be in big trouble
because if you're deficient in iodine as
a child your iq can go down
significantly like 13 points okay now
even if you're deficient iodine is adult
there are certain studies that show that
it can decrease by 15 points and that's
pretty significant but the crucial time
to get iodine is when the woman is
pregnant with that baby as well as when
they're breastfeeding
vitally important and so iodine is
involved in
the
creation of your brain and of certain
parts of the brain like the hippocampus
which is involved with learning
memory being able to navigate yourself
through different things
so primarily we have the hippocampus and
then the frontal lobe involved in
problem solving but of course
how much
of these parts of the brain are involved
with problem solving in iq i mean it's
pretty remarkable some people have had
huge
amounts of trauma and damage to their
brains i mean destruction of a good
portion of the brain and they still seem
to maintain their cognitive function and
their iq
so i just wanted to point that out
because we really don't know how much
brain we really need apparently we have
a lot of extra now the second mineral
that is the most important is zinc
zinc is involved in
hundreds of different enzyme reactions
okay it's definitely involved with the
hippocampus it's involved with making
neurotransmitters and if you're low on
zinc your iq is going down but this zinc
correlates with copper they both work
together so you need this zinc to copper
ratio and when you have children who
have autism for example there's nearly
always extremely low zinc and copper
levels but there's a huge correlation
between
high iq
and good zinc to copper ratios copper is
also very low in alzheimer's patients
also it's super concentrated in a
structure in your brain stem called the
locus aurelius which has everything to
do with your sleeping and then we have
magnesium magnesium is needed for making
atp
it's needed for energy in the brain and
if you don't have enough magnesium there
is a huge correlation between a lower iq
and so if we look at this right here we
have
you know seafood shellfish okay and
magnesium
salad vegetables leafy greens but you
can also get it in nuts and other foods
as well
but seafood shellfish very important to
get the top three i wanted to add a few
more vitamin d deficiency is also
correlated with learning disabilities
lower iq and cognitive function so
here's another one that's very very
important especially
if you are pregnant now iron also
correlates with the lower iq probably
because it's involved with anemia and
red blood cells and carry oxygen to your
brain
now there's a couple other things i
really need to cover related to
this cognitive function
and that has to do with this thing
called sugar sugar actually makes you
stupid it definitely correlates with a
lower iq
now that being said i do want to make a
very important point just because
someone has a high iq just because
someone is
so-called intelligent doesn't mean
that they are sane okay they could be
very intelligent but be
completely insane
and when i talk about insane i'm talking
about destructive right but when we're
talking about sugar we're talking about
blood sugar we're talking about even
diabetes so if your a1c is like above
seven
your recall is goes down okay your
ability to recall memories is
significantly affected
diabetics on average have a lower iq by
7.84
points
when someone is a diabetic and they have
higher sugar in their blood
that shrinks the hippocampus so we have
less hippocampus to work with which
means less capacity for memory less
capacity for learning and that is
intimately connected with iq
now if we take a look at the brain
that has insulin resistance okay it's
brain insulin resistance which is
always the case for someone that has
high sugar like a diabetic
there is a lot of destruction going on
in the neurons okay
and so when you feed the brain cells the
neurons too much sugar you end up
destroying those synapses and thank
goodness there's an alternative fuel to
bypass that whole thing and get the
energy that the neurons need so you can
have more intelligence and that
alternative fuel is ketones
now
what's interesting about ketones is that
your brain
is the organ that does not have to adapt
to
ketones like other parts of the body in
other words there's not a period of
three days where you have to
adapt or convert over to ketones it can
use ketones immediately if it's in the
blood
there's not a lot of
if any stored sugar in the brain the
brain does not store glycogen why
because there's no space
because when you're storing glycogen you
have to store a lot of water and there's
just no space so the brain is dependent
for its energy from the blood okay
and then that usually comes from your
liver primarily so if your liver is
damaged that can affect the brain but if
the brain has a choice between ketones
or glucose it will always pick ketones
as a primary fuel
and that way even if there's damage to
the brain
the brain cells can get energy so in
other words your brain is very
vulnerable to what diet you are on and
really what determines if there's
ketones in your blood or not
is really two things
glucose and your insulin levels so when
a person starts to go on the ketogenic
diet and they start lowering their
glucose
they notice also their insulin levels
lower they may still have problems and
they may not notice the significant
benefits of ketosis for quite some time
primarily because there's
this background
basic level of insulin in their blood at
all times
and if someone is obese they usually
have like three times the insulin levels
and this really has nothing to do with
their diet it's just that their baseline
insulin is just a lot higher than
someone that doesn't have a weight
problem so if you are watching and
you're overweight
just realize the more you lose weight
the more the insulin levels decrease the
more the benefits and it could take some
time so what are the takeaways from this
video
shellfish
seafood
big salads
and cut the sugar out and go on a low
carb diet now there's a lot more to talk
about the brain if you haven't seen this
video related to brain health this would
be a very interesting one to watch next